bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right I'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent plain Tamara Nova she
looks like either a sailor or a teacher
today I can't decide by the way after I
wore that leather shirt yesterday if you
guys watch CNBC saw one of the anchors
wear the same shirt Melissa Lee yeah is
that going around in the in the in the
women's world of fashion no it doesn't
matter
cuz I was first okay alright teacher
Paulina what's going on the door - so
just kidding
block Phi is now sponsoring lunch money
get money get paid go deposit money in
there interest-bearing account you can
earn up to eight point six percent
interest literally you can go and take
money you can wire it to block five
blocks I will convert it to a digital
dollar the deposit in their interest
bearing account for you and pay you up
to eight point six percent ap why we do
it we love it
I'm an investor in the company it is a
no-brainer you literally if you go open
up a bank account today and ask them for
their best savings rate you will get
like point oh five percent go get money
get paid with block five do your own
research
there's obviously risk but block five
coms last lunch money is a no-brainer
what's going on with door - so you know
the food delivery company door - yeah I
don't like talking about door - but go
ahead why not I met door - when they
were a sub ten million dollar valuation
business when I was at Facebook could
have invested didn't and they're not
even worse than that it couldn't work
there and didn't and now there are 16
billion dollar company oh no I have to
sneeze all right let's go no sneezing or
sneezing on this ship whew that was a
close call
okay well nobody cares about your
experience but we do care is that door -
now scored evaluation of 16 billion in
the time of coronavirus because
everybody's sitting at home everybody's
ordering food it's like a knife in my
back just getting twisted 16 billion
damn
dumb shout-out to Toni though what a job
literally built the 16 billion dollar
company super that's awesome so do you
think that this is a temporary thing or
do you think that this will catapult the
company into new heights
well doordash actually a lot of people
don't know this door - has the largest
market share in all food delivery I
think in the United States and also it
is accelerating when most others are
either going flat or even potentially
declining a little bit in 2020 so door -
is kind of the winner of one of the most
hot markets which is pretty cool I mean
it keeps raising capital like does it
hey if you got money you could spend it
and spend it efficiently and wisely then
you get to keep growing right money is
oxygen or it can kill you
what's going on with Facebook bang bang
okay so Facebook is buying a mapping
startup why the hell is Facebook getting
into maps I thought we already had Apple
and Google for that yeah but I think
what they're doing though is it's more
about photos on the ground than just
Maps Facebook well it's all kinds of
different things that you could do with
it like something as simple as imagine
if now every single business Facebook
page you can see photos just like you
could see on Google that's Yelp well
okay but Matt you think Facebook could
kill Yelp No maybe you don't think it's
Jewish momentum do you think it's worth
them trying no why
I don't want Facebook in my business you
could put all the small businesses
Facebook I actually think Facebook may
have more small businesses then Yelp
does on their platform yeah yeah and I
don't need them getting pictures of the
inside of my apartment no they're not
gonna get that they're gonna get it from
the street view right so I mean that's
just one example there's all kinds of
things that they can do with it
but again it's all about data it's all
about multimedia content and what I
don't know enough about this but they
may just be buying it for the team and
then shut down the company as well like
the product right so it's pretty cool
the company had raised twenty four
million dollars atomic
BMW eye adventures yes like a super you
know kind of star-studded list of
investors they raise 25 million bucks
financial details weren't disclosed so
could could have been flat could have
actually been a down round right that
there's a world where you could see
potentially that a company was being
built they ran out of cash they couldn't
raise more money so then they go through
and a q' hire again i don't know if that
happened here or not but like that would
line up with timing of rotavirus impact
how prevalent do you think it is for a
large company to buy a start-up just for
the team oh I think it happens really a
lot yeah if you started a technology
company right now and you were like a
star engineer and you decided okay this
isn't working I'm gonna go work at a
large tech company you basically hold
like an auction you go to all the
companies say okay who wants to buy my
company and they all kind of jockey for
who's gonna basically hire you yeah okay
right maybe I should do that just
kidding I don't want to Orcus you'd have
to learn how to be computer scientist
please okay what's going on mobile
payments with this outfit I can know
about dress for the job you want let me
teach you well something something you
you wouldn t shirt I don't know what job
you're trying to audition for we'll just
send you out on the Hudson River in a
boat sailor what's going on with my that
would be a pirate not a sailor
go ahead oh wait what's the difference
they're both on boats
yeah the Pirates are the bad people the
sailors are the good people unless I'd
be a pirate yeah unless you want to be a
banker okay all right let's go what's
going on so you know venmo
yeah you know cash app yeah I've heard
of cash up in some rap songs but I
haven't actually used it so they are
going crazy during coronavirus people
are up there paying each other via
mobile apps and they're becoming more
prevalent do you think we started that
trend with lunch money no oh what I do
think though is of course this was gonna
happen right people are using their
mobile devices to do more and more
things so now that there's technology
the less you basically have a bank on
your phone there's always been
technology no dress Oh for the last five
years
yeah you won't tell me yes I am I was
using venmo five years ago okay you're
using venmo how often do you use it like
all the time I use it I used it more
than than I do now
because you pay for [ __ ] she makes me
pay for everything this is all garbage
I'm just kidding no I know the comments
that you were about to leave do not
leave them I know what you're thinking
do not leave it because I'm looking
after you know but the whole thing is I
think cash app is a great example so a
lot of you don't know this but about 20%
of Americans are actually unbanked meat
or underbanked right so people we talk
about like foreign countries and
developing world all those unbanked but
here in the United States there's a lot
of people who don't have bank accounts
they don't have kind of thinking
resources they need so you get something
yes I need a bank account to have cash
app they don't where does it pull the
money from what do you mean how do you
load it with money doesn't I believe
this to be true I could be wrong some
people correctly if not but I believe
what you can do is you can sign up for
an account and basically somebody can
send you money and just hold it in the
cash app you never actually pull it into
a bank account and then you can see apps
as well right so kind of you know again
the idea is that you can create
technology to help a very large portion
of the population that's under banked or
unbanked so maybe they have a bank
account but it doesn't do everything
they need but of course this is gonna
happen like technology is going to
continue to improve and everything is
going to be on this device do you think
that we're gonna move towards a world
where it's even less like cash app and
venmo and these separate apps in a more
integrated experience like for example
with my Starbucks app it's they I use it
like a bank account kind of what do you
mean like when I go to Starbucks I just
do my app instead of yeah I mean
everyone wants you to go through their
application they want to vertically
integrate with banking services do all
that kind of stuff and that's fine
but that still is cash app venmo
these guys are gonna be just as problem
as well like don't like the world is
being digitized in the financial yeah
sector right and so everything will get
digitized by the way I have a long
Bitcoin short the [ __ ] bankers no
cursing kids
show don't Baker don't be a sailor short
the bankers be a pirate all right what's
going on one more story so we go to
Starbucks and I typically order ahead on
my mobile app but lately he's been like
no no don't order ahead
I'm like why is I like going up and like
talking to the people and ordering in
person they're cool people so yeah it
just it just feels so impersonal II just
walking you know saying he's grab your
drink and leave I know I hey how are you
guys doing today I like your haircut you
know you got a little funny voice like
you know he talks to everyone you know
I'm just a nice person trying to
brighten up their day they're sitting in
there there's not that many people
coming in right now
this woman was like wait I saw you on
Wednesday and he was like I was here
yesterday and yesterday afternoon and
you weren't here sobs showing up though
your work more than you are let's go
okay all right let's go what's going on
the prison escape this is a great story
okay so originally I always believed
that two inmates escaped Rikers Island
in New York but it turns out only one
because I don't know that's a little
suspicious cuz he originally said two
and then they were like oh no he said -
oh he said - I think I think the guys so
somebody got off Rikers Island Rikers
Island obviously is the famous prison he
jumped in the water and he started
swimming towards LaGuardia Airport I
don't know if he thought he was about to
hop on a plane or what he was doing and
they scooped him up real quick I read a
few articles and they were really funny
because they were like it's very unclear
oki got out because I was like a two
stories high he sometimes we conjure
recreation yard fence no that's after he
got off the he jumped off two-story I
don't know it was just like crazy
I read the internet I know what happened
but basically okay fun fact if you live
in Philadelphia is that where we went
yeah there's this massive high-security
maximum prison that's really old so
fascinating we like I mean it's old
they don't have prisoners in there
anymore but you can walk around it and
you can kind of see one of the cells
where a guy dug a tunnel and managed to
escape and then
was really really brutal winter and so
he he got out it was way too cold and he
voluntarily came back and like knocked
on the door to be let back in the prison
yes I'm a it's better in there it's like
warmer you guys got food and stuff yeah
let me just let me back in I'll come
back but yesterday the most important
part of the story was played a
completely has missed is the fact that
after the guy jumped over the recreation
yard fence he ran to the shore line
jumped in started swimming towards
LaGuardia and to prison guards saw this
happening they ran they jumped in the
water and when captured him and they
were like injured on their legs because
there's like wires and stuff in the
water
crazy crazy okay honestly I've gotta
escape from prison before what okay so
when I was in kindergarten my friend and
I devised the plan like over the course
of weeks of how we were gonna escape the
kindergarten area and like we memorize
how to get home and stuff but I'm not
that stupid I wasn't just about to like
take off so I was like let's let's see
you do it first so I convinced her to
run away and then she got in trouble and
she was like well she told me to I was
like no you're on your own dude during
the escape plan it's not my fault she
wanted to actually execute on it
I wouldn't see how it was you're one of
those people you're one of the people
who does all the big talk and you're
ready to go and then right when when
it's time to actually put your money
where your mouth is you're like oh you
just go and then after she got caught
you denied but I was the mastermind of
the plan it would she wouldn't have been
able to get away if I didn't devise such
a great plan for her she didn't get away
she got caught how great was the plan
obviously not that good my favourite
Prison Break of all time is somewhere I
think was in Europe there was a guy who
had a helicopter land on the prison and
break him out
there's a jailbreak with the hella cuts
a friend I want to have yeah that was
pretty cool I was gonna space balloons
okay so this is
interesting so this company is going to
allow people to enjoy the view from an
altitude of 100,000 feet in a balloon of
warm pressurized cabin complete with a
bar in a restroom in space like you kind
of can see the earth like look at how
cool but anyway so this would cost one
hundred twenty-five thousand dollars per
passenger and it's gonna happen in like
three and a half years supposedly I just
don't think it's gonna happen in three
years why you're telling me that they
don't know when we're gonna send people
with rockets literally use rockets to
send people to space but instead they're
gonna have a balloon that can do it in
three years it's a balloon wait guys
okay watch this watch this because he
doesn't read the links before lunch
money listen to this do you remember how
you told me there is not a chance in
hell that Tom Cruise is going a space to
film that movie yeah okay well NASA
confirmed that Tom Cruise will become
the first actor to be like shot in space
to film this movie see he confirmed that
Cruise will launch into space and stay
aboard the station it's not gonna happen
why not just because there confirm is
what they want to do it's not gonna
happen when do they say this is gonna
happen he would be the first actor to
lure extraterrestrial when do they say
this is gonna happen unclear okay so
they don't even know when a we're gonna
do it sure okay this is all marketing
you think yes they're not gonna you're
telling me that do you understand how
crazy it was that we just launched two
astronauts Lou the entire world was
watching we lucked two astronauts to the
International Space Station and then the
next person we're gonna launch is Tom
Cruise get at it here there is no way
did you also know that Lance the NSYNC
boyband
okay at one point pop star Lance Bass of
NSYNC boyband Fame planned a visit in
the early 2000s though that
did not pan out oh yeah so okay we
haven't launched anyone to space since
2011 from America but we're gonna do on
Qian NSYNC boy band member and Tom
Cruise
welcome to 2020 people but if you're
going to say like what Hollywood actor
with most likely like endure that and
actually go to space I would say it's
Tom Cruise no he's insane he's a [ __ ]
small exactly he could fit in both
things he has played a lots any easy
midges did you know that when they
filmed Top Gun they had to film a lot of
the scenes from below so he looked
taller than he really is I need just
saying what about policy Tom Cruise I
think it's like five six she doesn't
believe me we're gonna do it right now
how tall is Tom Cruise bang-bang put
yours off by age I told you I told you
come on
did you also know that Thomas Cruise
Mapple is his real name
yeah that's yeah yeah fourth yeah people
don't know that's his real name
what is it Tom yeah I told you Thomas
Cruise mapa thir the fourth that is Tom
Cruise's real name people don't know
that everyone is Tom Cruise no it's not
cruises his middle name mapa third is
his last name
you can't be a global superstar in the
movies with the last name Macca third
the fourth he's your kid oh if you could
why would he use Thomas mapa third
before I should be an actress
I'm obviously rubbing off on you okay
old ass [ __ ] ain't going to space I do
you know I think most of them are
actually shorter cuz you can't be a
freaking joke because they are I bet you
that the two guys who just went or
six-foot that's my guess hi all right
here we go like I didn't know that I
have a human google with me but we're
gonna figure it out right got it
centimeters
go ahead how tall is the average
astronaut just click on this on that
link right there yeah I don't know what
that means
well just divided by 12 know into
do we have time come on people still
watching come on ah okay wait Dennis oh
my god oh my god eight feet no we did
it's okay teacher we won't have you do
math anymore
all right guys lunch money time well go
say six foot three
Oh interesting it says 6.30 is the range
if the range is between 4 foot 8 and 6
so clearly web sites you use I'm not
sure this is why when we argue I end up
always winning is because you can't you
show up with things like oh the average
astronaut is 4 foot 8 to 63 can I'm like
okay but do you see when I had to guess
something if you can how tall is Tom
Cruise and I hit you with a 565 7 off by
1 inch the accuracy that I have in the
precision to my knowledge uncanny
alright listen once money time hundred
dollars if you sign up for the email in
the comments it's the pin comment on top
of the comment section if you sign up at
much money that's abstract Tom I will
send you a hundred dollars one of you I
will pick one of you and send a hundred
dollars just everyone knows the reason
why I'm turned like this is because
paleta has got a bunch of nonsense going
on right now and I don't want to subject
myself to that so when we sit when we
sit like this he's literally in the
trash like the trash is right here
alright your boy could shine anywhere
put me in the trash put me on Broadway
I'll be just fine that's it today for
lunch money we'll see you guys on Monday
that's what the pirate does holy bang
bang hope you guys enjoyed this episode
of lunch money as much as we did don't
forget lunch money's now sponsored by
block 5 so go check them out there's a
link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block lies
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got 3 products they can give you
a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
cooked
change I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
8.6 percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but 8.6
percent it's pretty compelling so click
on the link in the description say
thanks to the folks that block by
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoyed plain in the comment and we'll
see you guys tomorrow and be kind to
your friends